>> WHEN WLLOYD BAKER A FIGHT.
BAKER LAW.
>> WELCOME BACK NOW IS
FOCUSING ON YOUR FINANCES IS
ONE OF YOUR TOP  PRIO RITI ES
D IN WITH
THE CLARK COUNTY CREDIT UNION,
THE SPONSORS OF THIS NEXT
SEGMENT TO GET SOME TIPS CHECK
IT OUT. CRAIG WELCOME BIG
IRAQI GOOD TO SEE YOU GOOD TO
E TO IT IS NOT TIME TO START
THINKING ABOUT OUR NEW YEAR'S
RESOLUTIONS, ESPECIALLY
FINANCIALLY DURING THIS TIME
SO WHAT ARE YOU SEEING OUT
THERE WIND PEOPLE'S FINANCIAL
NEW YEAR'S RESOLUTIONS START
TO FALL WHEN THEY START OUT IT
BEGINNING IT TYPICALLY A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND THEY START
TO WANE OFF OF IT AND THAT OF
COURSE SO HOW DOES THE CLARK
COUNTY YOU NEED FEAR FOR US TO
HELP US SUSTAIN THAT THAT GOAL
YOU'REYO OUT.
>> THE EASIEST WAY TO STICK
YOUR FINANCIAL RESOLUTION IS
TO HAVE A PLAN AND WE HAVE
SEVERAL USUAL TIPS TO HELP
KEEP YOU ON TRACK FOR
EVERYTHING UP AN AUTOMATIC
PAYMENT, YOUR UTILITIES OR
RENT YOUR MORTGAGE OR CAR
PAYMENT EVEN YOUR SAVINGS IF IF
YOU DO THIS YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT LATE PAYMENTS AND
YOUR GREAT PAYMENT HISTORY
HELPS TO IMPROVE YOUR CREDIT.
>> VERY GOOD ADVICE AND WHAT
OTHER ADVICE THAT YOU GIVE US.
>> THERE'S AN OLD SAYING OUT
WITH THE OLD IN WITH THE NEW
AND THAT HOLDS TRUE FOR A
BUDGET AS WELL TOSS OUT THAT
OLD RETIRED BUDGET AND CREATE
A NEW FRESH WHEN IT MATCHES
YOUR CURRENT SITUATION FOR
EXAMPLE DURING COVID A LOT OF
US DURING THE SHUTDOWN
PROBABLY SIGNED GNUP A STREAMIN
SERVICES AND NOW THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TO BE AT HOME AS MUCH WE
MAY NOT BE USING ALL OF THOSE
THAT'S A GOOD TIME TO REDIRECT
THOSE FUNDS TOWARD YOUR
FINANCIANAL GOALS LIKE PAYING
DOWN CREDIT CARD DEBT FOR
BUILDING DIUP DIYOUR SAVINGS.
>> OKAY AND SPEAKING OF
SAVINGS HOW DO WE DO THAT HOW
DO WE BUILD UP OUR SAFETY OUR
VIEWERS AS SHOULD.
>> I THINK THE EASIEST WAY TO
DO THAT IS THROUGH DIRECT
DEPOSIT PAY YOURSELF FIRST
ALSO SOME OF YOUR OTHER
RESOLUTIONS MAY HELP WITH YOU
MADE YOU HAVE RESOLUTION QUIT
SMOKING OR STOP EATING FAST
FOOD RESTAURANTS, SO MUCH. YOU
CAN REDIRECT THOSE FUNDS TO
YOUR SAVINGS GOALS S S AND ALSO
SINGS CAN BE FUN, YOU CAN MAKE
A GAME OUT OF IT BECAUSE MATCH
GAME. WE HAVE WE TAKE THIS ONE
WEEK EVERY MONTH IN EVERY
PURCHASE YOU MAKE MATCH THAT
PURCHASED HERE THAT DOLLAR NOT
YOUR SAVINGS ACCOUNT OR PUT A
CAP ON IT AND EVERY TIME YOU
MAKE A PURCHASE THAT WEEK FOR
A FEW DOLLARS IN SAVINGS AND
IF YOU'RE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
GET A RAISE IN THE NEXT YEAR.
YOU CAN APPLY A PORTION OF
THAT TO YOUR AUTOMATIC SAVING
GOALS ALALL THESE TIPS COMBINED
CAN REALLYRE MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN YOUR SAVINGS BALUCH I LOVE
THAT IF YOU MAKE IT AGAIN
THAT'S A GREAT WAY TO GET THE
KIDS INVDSOLVED STARD T TED ACH
OF EARLY
>> YOU CA YN MA YKE THOSE BIG
THERMOMETERS AND CAN COLOR
MINUTES, HE IS CERISTAIN GOALS
THAT KIDS CAN DO THAT AND IT
MAKES IT FOR THE WHOLE FAMILY.
OH THAT'S A GOOD IDEA WHAT
OTHER TOOLS YOU GUYS HAVE COOK
COUNTY CREDIT UNION FOR
FAMILIES TO KEEP ON TRACK.
YEAH, THE BEST TOOL IS DIRECT
DEPOSIT. AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
OTHER FREE FINANCIAL TOOLS ON
OUR WEBSITE WE HAVE A.
>> DE CALCULATLCOR LCLCLCBUDGLCC
CALCULATOR ATWE HATAVE ATA DEATT
PAYOFF COACH. WE HAVE A
CALCULATLCOR FOR FOFOSAVINGS GO
WE ALSO SOME SPECIALTY SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS LIKE A CHRISTMAS CLUB
ACCOUNT AND A VACATIONCA CACACA
ACCOUNT AND OPEN AN ACCOUNT
WITH CLARK COUNTY CREDIT UNION
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF ALL OF
THESE SPOTS PROGRAMS MORE YOU
CAN VISIT US AT CCC ULV DOT
ORG OR GIVE US A CALL AT 7 OH
2, 2, 2, 8, 2, 2, 2, 8, WE
WOULD LOVE TO HELP YOU STICK
YOUR FINANCIAL RESOLUTIONS.
>> THANK YOU CLARK COUNTY
CREDIT UNION FOR SPONSORING
THAT SEGMENT GIVE THEM A CALL
AT 7 '02, 228-2228 OR VISIT
SCI FI C U L V DOT ORG AND
THAT'S WHER